give your other hands
[Music]
[Applause]
dang it hold this lead for a second
[Applause]
all right i got him i got him
here let me see your hands are you gonna
get bit
right here
miss your hands
you better let me see your hands
get up and pull your hands out
all right i got his hands
[Applause]
all right
first up give me your hand you fucking
pull me down
get up
pull yourself up
let me see your other hand let me see
your other hand
can't fucking get up
[Applause]
stop resisting stop resistance
[Applause]
[Applause]
stop resisting all right listen
you're coming out i know that all right
so stop being stupid i'm not i'm trying
to couple
let me get up will you got cuffs
come on
here i'll get up
just don't put them on tight
i'm serious yeah okay
right i'm serious with your other hand
give me your hands bro i don't
don't fucking care
i go to the hospital right yeah all
right tease me
give me your other hand
give it a shot
you're making this longer than it needs
to be all right well i fucking said i'm
trying to get up man give me that he
said please don't put in the handcuffs
i'm not going
how do we get out of here
[Applause]